three crypto bosses have just died all  within the last few weeks all under  suspicious circumstances Tien Tien  kulander co-founder of a crypto trading  platform died in his sleep at the age of  30. Nikolai mushagan age 29 drowned on a  beach in Puerto Rico shortly after  posting some strange tweets that the CIA  was after him and Via cheslov Terran  co-founder of another trading platform  died in a helicopter crash this was  right after another unnamed passenger  canceled plans to fly with him at the  last minute investigators have not ruled  out foul play in any of these cases were  these deaths simply a coincidence or is  there more to this story than meets the  eye right now rumors are flying about  how